this video was brought to you by
Skillshare hi welcome to another
ColdFusion video there's something
interesting going on with energy
production in the United States it
signals a growing change in the trend of
energy generation and I find it
interesting to watch so what's going on
electricity generated by renewable
sources such as solar wind and hydro
have exceeded coal-fired power in the
United States for a record 40 days this
is according to a report based on US
government data released earlier this
month for some this doesn't sound like
much but as we'll see it's actually very
significant on the flip side in the area
of renewable energy there's also some
serious questions that we should be
asking we'll explore that later in the
video but for now let's kick off the
episode TV according to the Institute
for energy economics the boost for
renewables is due to a seasonal increase
in low cost solar and hydropower
generation this is alongside an overall
slump in electricity demand of 3 percent
the slump has been caused by pandemic
related reduce demand from commercial
and industrial sectors as you'll soon
see hydro generation is actually falling
as well so it's wind and solar that are
rapidly increasing for many years on
this channel we've been taking note of
the Fallen solar prices and increase in
efficiency now up to almost 50% with the
latest research in the United States
every day from March 25th solar wind and
hydro plants produced more electricity
than coal-fired plants this accounts for
about 1/5 of the United States power
requirement the longest back-to-back
stretch previously was 9 days in 2019
and in total in 2019 renewables Bicol on
just 38 days at sporty times throughout
the year so over 40 straight days of
renewable energy beating coal is very
very significant
when power production needs to be ramped
down like in this pandemic coal tends to
be the first power source that's cut by
utilities this is because renewable
sources are cheaper to operate and are
often backed by state clean energy
mandates so the full story is a bit more
murky when government led initiatives
are making alternative power sources
more attractive still though from
strictly technological standpoint I find
it very interesting that this is
happening according to current financial
analysis Cole's percentage in the u.s.
power generation market is expected to
collapse into single digits by 2025 in
2014 coal supplied thirty eight point
six percent of the nation's electricity
needs and by 2019 that figure had
dropped to twenty three point four coal
demand is forecast to fall a whopping 20
percent this year while renewable energy
generation will grow 11 percent this 11
percent growth is due to grid operators
flavouring their lower operating costs
natural gas prices are also dropping
compounding the move away from coal this
story of renewables overtaking coal is
as much about the collapse of coal as
the rise of renewables there have been
many coal company bankruptcies as well
as a production over capacity this has
all led to capital investment drying up
interestingly according to IBS world
statistics the energy production of
hydroelectricity is also falling due to
more droughts hydro production has
fallen 0.7 percent over the last five
years so solar and wind are making up
more of the difference in the renewable
sector
amidst this backdrop the US Energy
Information Administration forecasts
large amounts of wind and solar capacity
are being added to the grid as
governments and businesses seek cleaner
power sources often replacing retiring
coal plants on the flip side the
Department of Energy has warned that
over Alliance on solar and wind can
reduce the dependability of the grid
this is because the power generation is
intermittent fossil fuel plants can
store the fuel on site and are more
reliable though if you've been following
this channel for a while you'll know
what the solution here is electrical
energy storage so when the sun is
shining and the wind is blowing we can
use utility-scale batteries to store the
excess amount of energy though when the
Sun isn't shining and the wind isn't
blowing these batteries can feed back
the energy onto the grid it's very clear
now that the potential for electric
energy storage is huge from electric
cars and aircraft to utility storage
over the last decade a surge in
lithium-ion battery production has led
to an 85 percent decline in prices this
makes electric vehicles and energy
storage commercially viable for the
first time in history battery technology
has been getting better as well this is
a 1,700 milliamp hour battery from a
1994 laptop and this is a five thousand
milliamp hour battery in a phone but
batteries are about to get a lot better
the financial incentive to create even
better batteries is now huge much larger
than it's ever been when we talk about
battery technology a lot of people still
think it's 2015 and there's never going
to be better batteries because there's
no incentive but just think the company
that creates a breakthrough battery and
licenses this technology could own a
multi-billion dollar market UBS
estimates that over the next 10 years
the energy storage market in the United
States could grow as much as four
hundred and twenty six billion dollars
and in a post pandemic world this could
be even more
so when there's a demand for better
technology there will be companies
trying to provide that technology for
utility scale storage as even other
methods beyond lithium-ion batteries
such as liquid batteries or flow
batteries and currently there's a
massive race that's on even the other
week Samsung came out with a very
interesting scientific paper on a new
method of a solid-state battery which
solves the two major problems
surrounding the technology the
elimination of dendrite formation which
would kill the battery in the long run
and the elimination of low internal
efficiency this battery has 50% more
energy density and a 200% longer life
cycle than previous solid state efforts
so even today the batteries that we have
are viable for utility energy storage
but they're only going to get cheaper
and better in the long run these are
some very interesting times indeed so on
the flip side of all of this we should
be thinking about the other side of the
equation while it's good that we're
looking at alternative energy sources we
have to ask ourselves some hard
questions how much energy is going into
building solar panels from the mining of
the materials to the transportation for
wind turbines how much energy is being
used for the same processes including
construction if we weigh up all of this
what is the total net energy output how
long or solar and wind structures last
how would the sector look if there
wasn't any government help these are
hard questions to answer and it depends
on the efficiency of the specific
equipment used and the supply chains
involved so are there alternatives to
the alternatives well in this vein
there's been a growing movement among
scientists and engineers to revisit
nuclear power in a big way the reactor
technology that we have today isn't the
same dangerous equipment used in the 60s
and 70s plus it's one of the most energy
efficient processes known to man
for the best possible nuclear solution
you can check out my video on thorium
reactors it's actually pretty
interesting technology other methods
such as a revamped brand of garbage to
energy generation as done in Ethiopia a
viable for countries with smaller energy
needs the rebbe waste of energy works by
taking in the garbage keeping it in a
bunker for about five days to allow the
moisture to sip and then burning it at
about a thousand degree centigrade
turning that into heat energy that is
then able to move steam turbines that in
turn generate electricity simultaneously
were able to capture we would have been
polluted gases and turn them into inert
materials and make sure that there is no
major pollution from
[Music]
we have this facility that is taking
this with as much garbage with almost a
total of 500 milligrams of garbage for
the whole year now you don't have to
dump that in new landfills that is land
now that could be used for constructing
houses are doing other projects we have
precious land that is now kept out of
being a storage for garbage forever
I really do enjoy engineers thinking
outside the box when it comes to these
things so the Institute energy for
economics and finance report concluded
quote short-term economic uncertainty
caused by the pandemic and the recent
collapse in oil prices may slow down
this transition slightly but the trend
is clear coal is being driven to the
brink by continued low gas prices and
steady additions of wind and solar it's
interesting to see the shift of low-cost
solar and wind actually making such
meaningful contributions to energy in
the United States the next ten years
should be very interesting to say the
least
coal is falling off a cliff and
renewables are starting to rise that
being said we should ask ourselves about
the bigger picture of all the moving
parts in this story of energy so what do
you guys think let me know in the
comments section below
I'd like to thank Skillshare for
sponsoring this video
Skillshare is one of the best ways to
learn a new skill online and now is one
of the best times to do so I've enjoyed
this series art of the start turning
ideas into high growth businesses by a
Guy Kawasaki it has some practical steps
about landing a business that really
makes you think there are some
well-thought-out steps of important
philosophies and frameworks with
examples from companies such as Google
and McDonald's what are the kind of
questions that you should be asking
yourself when starting a business what
is your business purpose what are three
simple words that define what you're
doing
Skillshare is giving away two free
months of premium membership to the
first 1000 people who click the link in
the description below
after that it's only around $10 a month
okay so thank you all for watching the
video I hope you enjoyed it and if you
did feel free to subscribe to this
channel so my name is - gogo and you've
been watching cold fusion and I'll see
you again soon for the next video
cold fusion thinking
[Music]
you